ich bin im Internet auf dieses komplett
geniale schreibtischdesign gestoßen mega
geil nimmt kaum Platz weg und man kann
es einfach aufklappen sieht ultra cool
aus Design einfach auf ein ganz anderen
Level dachte ich mir okay brauche ich
muss ich haben einaken das Ding kostet
einfach über zweieinh000 € und ja also
das gebe ich nicht von Schreibtisch aus
deswegen will ich mir den Tisch selber
bauen und zwar für nur 10% der Kosten
aber wie genau funktioniert das Teil der
Designer Robert von ambrix hat er
richtig einen rausgehauen passend zum
falb Schreibtisch hier übrigens bares
Android und zwar Google Pixel fold mit
riesen Display und von Android wird
dieses Video brübgens auch unterstützt
also man sieht hier dass jede dieser
leisten ein Scharnier hat und damit auch
an der Tischplatte befestigt ist und
damit auch das klappen eben möglich ist
zwei der Leisten sind an der Wand
festgemacht und dann passiert irgendwie
Magie und aus dem Nichts entsteht ein
Schreibtisch vor allem wie sind die
ganzen leisten D miteinander verbunden
also irgendwas muss drin sein ich weiß
nicht Schnur vielleicht aus dem wikel
sieht man es ganz gut da sind Langlöcher
drin und dann geht da sicher eine Stange
durch weil wir ja genaue Maße brauchen
und nicht einfach so drauf losbauen
können wird unser neuer Schreibtisch
einmal in CAD modelliert dabei war es
echt nicht leicht überall die richtigen
Verhältnisse abzuschätzen gerade was die
Tischplatte unten angeht die ja so
abgestuft abgerundet ist dann kommen
noch diese Leisten dran und damit ist
dann auch der zusammengeklappte Zustand
fertig diese Leisten brauchen ja jetzt
noch Langlöcher wo später eine Stange
durchgefädelt wird um die sich die
leisten nicht nur drehen werden sondern
an der sie auch entlang rutschen werden
wie ihr das hier gerade seht wir haben
jetzt zum ersten Mal mit Gelenken in CAD
gearbeitet und na ja also das sah jetzt
erstmal nicht so vielversprechend aus ja
Alter was passiert
hier junge ich hab dann also mit einem
anderen Programm jede einzelne Latte an
seine aufgeklappte Position gebracht und
dann noch mal ein zweites Loch an der
Endposition gemacht diese beiden Löcher
müssen dann noch miteinander zu einem
Langloch verbunden werden und schon kann
sich die Leiste zwischen eingeklapptem
und aufgeklappten Zustand bewegen ohne
dass die Stange irgendwas blockiert
animiert und aus Holz sieht das ganze
dann so aus und das Holz und auch die
anderen Materialien die brauchen wir
jetzt und da muss ich drauf achten das
wen nicht über die 265 € kommen also 10%
vom Originalpreis das ist Original ist
aus Eiche ich habe hier in der Garage
aber noch eine richtig geile
Bambusplatte vom camperumbau ich kann ja
dank Multitasking auf Android einfach
zweimal Google Chrome öffnen so links
die eichenplatte rechts die Bambusplatte
aufmachen hier beim Baumarkt ist die
Bambusplatte um 10 % länger aber dafür
die eichenplatte um 10 % dicker schenkt
sich nichts kosten tut beides gleich
viel und damit haben wir fürs Holz 86,20
€ so die Eiche brauchen wir jetzt nicht
mehr was wir aber brauchen ist der
Taschen Rechner also 86,20 € dann
brauchen wir noch die Scharniere 30
Scharniere aus Edelstahl mit Schrauben
gibt's hier für 8,999 € plus die
Metallstange die durch die ganzen Latten
durchgeht da hat wir noch eine auf Lager
die haben wir damals hier gekauft der
Meter kostet da
2,96 sind wir bei 9815 da kommen jetzt
noch ein paar Schrauben Dübel und
weagscheiben dazu für 1,74 € und dann
sind wir bei
99,89 € krass das sind nur 5% vom
originalkaufpreis von 2000 € aberich
auch arbeitsau dabei und da kommen wir
jetzt zu wir haben uns ja dafür
entschieden dass wir den Tisch aus
Bambus machen deswegen habe ich mir
jetzt hier mal diese riesenplatte Bambus
geholt die Platte ist zu groß für unsere
Werkstatt und daraus werden wir jetzt
diese ganzen einzelnen Streifen
rausschneiden ich habe mich jetzt der
einfachkeitalber erstmal dazu
entschieden das Teil in der Mitte mit
der kapsig auseinander zu schneiden weil
ich es einfach nicht auf die tischkreiss
kriegt das Teil viel zu lang ja der
einfachkeitber
[Musik]
und weil diese Leisten natürlich alle
unterschiedlich lang werden müssen habe
ich mir eine Zeichnung drauf geladen wo
die ganzen Maße drauf sind und die
Arbeiten jetzt nacheinander ab aber mit
Schutzausrüstung 91
C ich soll mit dem ftben Android
eigentlich auch ziemlich geil was filmen
[Musik]
können gut und das
nächste und was auch krass auf Pixel
fold ist ist das hier aufklappen man
kann selfies machen mit der Frontkamera
die natürlich krasser ist oder kein
selfie machen sondern vloggen man kann
damit vloggen und selber sehen schönere
Optik und ein besseres Handgefühl wird
jede Leiste noch mal von jeder Seite
angefasst also mit einer Fräse so leicht
schräg
gemacht für die Langlöcher durch die
später die Stange kleiten soll die alle
Leisten zusammenhält kommt jetzt unsere
erste Leiste in die CNC die das Langloch
mal eben
[Musik]
zaubert sieht jetzt mal so
aus und das funktioniert das Teil kann
sich jetzt
drehen und auch
sliden und davon brauchen wir einfach
noch ganz viele
[Musik]
mehr wir sind jetzt schon mal einige
fertig und idealerweise soll wir jetzt
auch da die Stange reinschieben
können so und jetzt soll sich jedes
einzeln bewegen können und eben hoch und
runter schieben können also auch das
allein schon einfach abstrakte Kunst als
nächstes ist die Tischplatte in der CC
gelandet die bekommt dann nämlich ihre
verrückte Form verliehen mit den ganzen
Abstufungen und somit ist die
Tischplatte fertig sieht richtig crazy
aus eine heftige Form diese ganzen
Kanten hier g bisschen abschleifen genau
auf jeden Fall Moment hier sind übrigens
unsere Scharniere die sehen so aus
Edelstahl und die müssen jetzt da so
hier müssen dran gemacht werden und hier
und hier und hier und hier und hier
quasi überall auch an diese LE mit den
Langlöchern da muss es auch dran und
dann kann man das hin so richtig nice
auf und zu klappen und damit die alle
exakt gleichmäßig befestigt werden
können haben wir noch eine bohrvorlage
[Musik]
gedesign und dann 3D
gedruckt und damit können jetzt die
Löcher Ben ich habe dafür noch mal die
ganzen leisten hier sortiert ich nehme
mal das mittlere raus das kann ich jetzt
einfach so warte ich zeig euch das mal
jetzt kann ich das ein so nehmen h
einfach drauf schieben dann nehme ich
hier ein Akkuschrauber und B
[Musik]
rein zweimal hab dann quasi die Bohen
genau da wo sie hingehört zack zack
nicht schlecht D ich mir hier ein
schönes Scharnier raus genau dann fällt
ein auf dass auf der falschen Seite
gemacht hat die bohungen aber es halb zu
wild noch
mal warte ich wollte gar nicht die
bohhfe dran
schrauben
sondern das
Scharnier ja fehlen nur noch 30
[Musik]
Stück diese ganzen leisten habe ich ganz
alleine jetzt gerade
schon tich dran die auch gerade übrigens
noch so eine Phase angefräst bekommen
hat wie ihr gerade hier schön
eingeblendet sieht in der Boll genau und
jetzt muss sie glatt geschliffen werden
und die schleif ich jetzt hier
großflächig gleich mit der Maschine aber
hier am Rand schleifft das jetzt mit der
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Hand jetzt geht das Stück noch und damit
kommt dann hier den tirisch die Löcher
rein
[Musik]
jetzt kommt der coolste Arbeitsschritt
von
allen und zwar das Einölen
einmal schönen Öl üers Holz drüber und
schon kriegt es eine viel viel schönere
Farbe und ist geschützt das ist
natürlich das
[Applaus]
Wichtigste so wir sind jetzt gerade hier
im Gästezimmer da wo auch noch das
wunderbare Minecraft Bett steht und das
selbstgemachte Bett genau da wird der
Schreibtisch aufgebaut wo also am besten
wahrscheinlich hier an der Wand oder
Biss überlegen hier ist halt noch so
ein Lampe lichtanschluss aber eigentlich
W es ganz cool direkt da drunter zu
machen also wenn dann irgendwann mal
hier eine Lampe steht hat man am
Schreibtisch direkt Licht das glaube ich
wäre ziemlich cool okay Set geklärt der
kommt dahin der passt dahin jetzt muss
den Spaß nürlich erstmal noch
zusammenbauen so dafür muss ich die noch
mal
[Musik]
sortieren
funktioniert richtig gut also ich glaube
ich glaube das könnte auf an
funktionieren sit so crazy aus diese
[Musik]
Form so und der
letzte heftig das sieht so krass aus
also große Props an Designer das ist so
cool hier ins Ende kommt jetzt noch so
eine Schraube dran damit das ja nicht
rauskommt auf die andere Seite hier
natürlich auch und dann sollte jetzt das
funktionierenah
das ist so krass das in echt zu sehen es
macht gar keinen Sinn das so zu
[Musik]
sehen kan
sch und da hängt da der fertige faltbare
ultra Platz sparende Designer
Schreibtisch für 100€ Material Kosten
statt 2000 € Kaufpreis als allerletzten
Feinschliff bekommt da zum Schutz der
Wand jetzt noch diese
Stoffpads so jetzt kann man sie einfach
so entlang ziehen dann kommt der Sessel
so dann kann man h
arbeiten
ist auf jeden Fall entspannt wir vem
gestimmer kein Schreibtisch und schon
mal geil wenn hier jemand zu Gast ist
dass auch Laptop irwas machen
kann hey Google mach ein
Foto das sieht echt geil aus jetzt wenn
ich noch mal auf de Foto sehe ich Po
jetzt schon mal behind the scenes als
Community
Tab das super geil also das mit dem
klappesign ist ultra nice
[Applaus]
B ein bisschen überrascht dass es direkt
funktioniert auf anib ja da bin ich echt
überrascht es wackelt ein bisschen in
die
Richtung aber in die Richtung ist super
stabil vielen Dank an Android die mit
den Pixel fold dieses Video unterstützt
haben kleiner fun fact foldbles gibt's
nur auf Android also checkt auf jeden
Fall mal den Link in der
Videobeschreibung aus für mehr Infos und
ich bin damit raus